Film Courage: How do you write suspense?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer: Again
painfully.
I think it’s setting up that world.
For me I love setting up that world maybe
because I was a photographer and love and
I love where I can describe the room, describe
the sound and then I know for me terror isn’t
in your face.
It’s like if things are quiet and then all
the sudden you start to hear my voice and
then suddenly you hear a cup crash in the
other room and we both turn, that’s scary
to me versus music.
I try to…I thinking pacing is a great part
of it and I know to have the audience want
something that they don’t want to see but
are curious about so you try to lead them
on as long as possible before you frustrate
the audience by doing it.
I’m still working on it.
Hopefully the next couple ones will be more
suspenseful but it’s a work in progress
I guess in terms of getting the right “Ahh!”
Or like on the edge of the seat feeling so
still working on that craft.
Film Courage: What did ALL ROADS TO PEARLA
teach you about pacing?
Van: It’s everything.
It’s rhythm, it’s how you get into a story,
it’s how you leave, you can be in what part
too long, one scene too long, the dialogue
can go on a little too much, so it’s like
being a DJ, it’s like you have to know when
to start the crowd, when to get them going,
when to settle them down, when to exit and
that comes through I guess experience and
trying to which thankfully I was able to make
this one and learn from issues I might have
faced and wasn’t so successful on and try
to get better at that but pacing is absolutely
everything.
The editing is everything and it’s too that
right, it’s like rhythms again, it’s like
music.
I see that in composition too.
Rhythms is super important.
Film Courage: How do you know when to leave
a scene?
Van: Again, I think that’s subjective in
taste.
So you build your taste of things that you
like so I would take it like if I was watching
this film how would I feel?
If it’s too long it’s really being an
honest assessment of yourself and having fresh
eyes on it and helps other people who understand
what you’re trying to do and take those
criticism because man this is we don’t need
this.
Questions For The Viewers: When you think
of pacing, what movie do you think of first?